okay hi we're back about A+ for those of
you watching on the computer who missed
the show itself means we did good today
alright here are the quest lockout yeah
no one walks out of a free show with air
conditioning Michael Moore does the
momentum of progressive figures like
better work or Andrew Gilliam in red
state demonstrate that the Democratic
Party needs to move further left in
order to win a nice soft ball right down
the middle of the bomb for you the party
does the people are already there the
majority of Americans take the liberal
position on nearly every single issue
seventy percent want Medicare for all
eighty-two percent believe women should
be paid the same as men I mean just go
down the whole list climate change
everything we're a liberal country and
we win by three million votes and we've
won six of the last seven presidential
popular votes
yeah the Republicans have won only once
in 30 years but I will add that's how
much they don't want the event like you
say something like Medicare for All
American people they do want that
majority I didn't know it was up to
seventy but they are absolutely 100%
clueless about what things cost they
have no idea when they ask it what
should we cut oh yes let's cut we have
spent too much what should we cut they
say you know what we need to cut foreign
aid that's part of listen to sorry you
didn't it'll lose I just yeah I'm in the
budget I said the Podesta when I
interviewed for this I said I said why
couldn't you just say free college well
we did say free Community College and
you have to work to pay it back and I
said that's how we lose elections right
do what they do say free college yeah
but we hadn't figure out how we're gonna
pay for it who cares
just say it yeah
[Applause]
not later and this thing that Democrats
need to move left is such
I mean as you said Michael and my fellow
Michigander the you know the people are
here with that what we're talking about
is the Democrats moving to the center to
America and you know yeah well thank you
for there except for all those that want
to kill you it's a large basket of
deplorable that's wrong we don't want to
kill you that's that's what makes us
liberal we actually the blood would be
like bad here's the thing when we're
back in charge
or should I say if I'd like to believe
when we're back in charge here's what's
gonna happen all the people watching out
there who voted for Trump when we get
Medicare for all we're you're gonna be
covered too when we don't go into the
next war we won't send your children off
to war either yeah I mean that's that's
you get the benefit from all the things
we're gonna fix climate change you'll
get to live we're not gonna go from
promised that he talked about universal
health care that's why I think he talked
about I know that's and then he handed
over the policy to the to the same old
Republicans in Congress yeah but the
reason Wright won the primary because he
was not like all the Republic just put
out let's just put out the slogan that's
gonna get the most voters because we
kind of saw Republicans do that and they
want yeah and then the dog caught the
car and they didn't have a plan and
they're still there right and he's not
going anywhere right I think Democrats
should be better than that they should
make an example I don't want to be
better anymore I want to win right I
want day
[Applause]
this accent the point
remember what Trump's health care plan
was what he was running something
terrific that was yeah we're gonna
replace something to about you that
you've dined on that for six months and
then he said I'm gonna give you health
care that's better better cheaper and
covers every bit of your example people
exactly right vote for what they will be
I think difference is that once we say
it we're actually smart we're not stupid
and and we will actually work to try to
get people those things will fail at
some of it but at least the Democrats
are going to start aspiring us something
and having a spine to do it you're never
gonna win if one side plays by rules
having serious ideas that can be
executed but they do have that it's just
getting into a mysterious idea when it
comes to things like how Medicare for
all would work for example if you look
at Bernie's matter or you know sense I
agree
right like it made no sense major system
we don't know man get somebody right let
me get to a few other questions Steve
helped him given what you now know would
you have advised David Cameron you were
an advisor to former prime I was I like
I liked him a lot and British
conservatives are not crazy
conservatives like in this country okay
so one thing that's really we worked
very hard at that yes I know Maggie
Thatcher would you have advised David
Cameron not to hold to the brexit vote
yeah I I did actually advised him not to
do that but I had a different view which
you probably won't agree with which is
that rather than having a referendum
which I was certain would be divisive
and end up in a mess that the better
thing to do is just be to say clearly in
an election in your platform we think we
need to leave the EU because we believe
in democracy we believe the people that
make the decisions in a country should
be accountable to the people and the EU
is an unaccountable bureaucracy that's
what we believe so that's what we're
standing on rather than leaving this
open question when no one really knew
what would happen
at the end of it if you to put it in
your official party program you could
have developed a plan and a policy and
you wouldn't have this mess that's my D
mm-hmm okay I was hoping it'd be a
little more bloody than that okay Thomas
far-right media personalities such as
Alex Jones and Tucker Carlson gained and
are they gaining influence or losing it
it's a good question I had to do with
the platform's you've got most of the
radio stations of this country owned by
corporations that have an explicit and /
right-wing bias you've got a television
network created by a billionaire who did
this in to other country did this to two
other countries before he got to our
country and and you know lost a hundred
million dollars a year for the first
five years major investment here America
lost seventeen million dollars oh you
know it was terrible thing now they are
willing the the conservatives are
willing to invest in the infrastructure
you've got right you've got entire teams
of people who are just scrubbing
Wikipedia all day long on behalf of
right-wing football I mean it just goes
on the long game is crazy
conservatives are much more interesting
when they're crazy they come up with
like a you know an ounce comes up with
like great little green man things that
I I don't know where it gets alex is a
performer yeah and whereas if you when
liberals go crazy it sounds like NPR I
don't know I can do pretty good crazy
there's a couple of things I just want
to say you could but you really can't
put talked of Carson in the same
catechism again from the other side of
the fence people would say we've got to
have this because because the rest of
the mass meters so dominated by the
other argument it's just about that's
again the rest of the mass
media is dominated by facts well that's
another one you've got to have that
you've gotta use the right-wing
infrastructure because there is an
opinion that's your opinion that's true
well it's an opinion show right exactly
in light of the article written by this
is video Catherine that written by
Reagan's daughter patty Davis how do you
imagine I don't know what that is
referring to how do you ever see so she
was sexually assaulted okay how do you
imagine the OIC how do you imagine the
Kavanagh accusation would be handled if
the accuser were a conservative woman
rather than a liberal I think we kind of
already saw this happen weren't some of
Roy Moore's alleged victims conservative
option yeah I think so
they were that's my recollection I mean
right so and what happened was that
people rallied around the accused child
molester right yeah because he was in
their party he was he had he had a
little R next to his name and and not a
D we have a Democratic senator in
Alabama which just shows anything's
possible if your opponent children
[Applause]